this is Jonathan Ferguson the keeper of
firearms and artillery at the Royal
armories Museum in the UK which houses a
collection of thousands of micro weapons
from throughout history and on this
episode he's taking another look at the
World War II era Weaponry of the
Tactical shooter hell let loose Hammer
should not obscure as much of the rear
sight Notch as it does here that's
borderline unusable I would suggest for
combat purposes you should be able to
see about twice as much if you like this
kind of content we've got a brand new
season of Lodo airing on the channel
right now new episodes will launch every
Sunday and you can already check out our
most recent episode all about the art of
dual wielding in pop culture right let's
take a look at more of the weapons of
Hell let loose
foreign
so famous that its name is used for all
sorts of things that aren't Bazookas but
this is a bazooka M1 or M1A1 I assume
it's the M1A1 ours is an M1A1
the site is well represented simple
sheet metal rear aperture and another
sheet metal foresight now in reality you
are picking one of these three four
sites to aim it seems that in the game
you're only ever using the lowest
elevation as it were so by picking the
middle side you're raising the muzzle
slightly to count the drop of the
projectile because I gather the the
rocket motor isn't sufficient to
overcome or the burn time at least is
not sufficient to keep the thing flying
straight and level it does drop like a
projectile would drop as I understand it
and as the game depicts it so in terms
of effect realism well the visual
effects are I think great the explosions
Sparks smoke that all looks quite
naturalistic and real that might be a
bit too much fire I would have to go
back and watch some some archive footage
to remind myself
um but there may be a little bit too
much flame from the explosion of these
things they're not not high explosive
per se they are meant to be armed
piercing
all right the Browning's looking good
the Browning m1919 specifically the A6
with that distinctive butt stock it's a
bit of a fudge if you don't know the
background of this thing it's really uh
meant to be an in place machine gun a
medium machine gun arguably even a heavy
machine gun the point is it's not it was
never designed for shoulder firing
certainly not and not really hip firing
either it's clutched with a bipod and a
handle and about stuck in a pistol so it
did the job but it was exceedingly heavy
and cumbersome having said that it's
belt fed Firepower 3006 cartridges it's
if you've got a sufficient unit of a
gunner to wield it it's a a real Force
multiplier I suppose you'd call it this
thing sounds great it's this has the
punch of the machine gun a slightly
weird lighting glitch I think which I've
noticed before the lighting is really
good but the muzzle flash I don't think
the muzzle flash should be lighting
inside of the site protectors they are
pretty well I mean it would to some
extent don't get me wrong but the inside
faces of the the site protectors are
lighting up like there's a torture being
shot on them or something and um not
something I paid attention to when
firing machine guns which only happens
occasionally but something to maybe sort
of Benchmark because I know virtual
Lighting systems don't don't necessarily
behave like the real world that's just
Ray tracing or something so it's
something that I picked up on if you're
shooting a machine gun for real and it
certainly for being shot at least say
you're not going to pay attention to
that and they're even in the game I
don't think
foreign
pattern or model this is modeled very
well I think all the details have seem
to be there we don't operate the bipod
in this but in case you're interested
the handguard is also the bike board and
the bayonet thing here now I can't
recall what the bayonet gameplay is like
in this
but I'm guessing the FG isn't one of
those that you can use and if you wish
close your whiteboard legs and you have
a very compact weapon with a Bayonet on
the end so yeah just really just
summarizing the gun at this point
because it looks really good the sights
are not adjustable in the game clearly
the real thing has a really cool feature
where you press the site down dial in
the range you want so we're at 200
meters on the in the game but for about
500 we turn it to five we let the site
up and the site has now popped up and
there is a sight Mount and I believe
there's a scope option for this gun in
the game as well so this always has this
dovetail for the site pretty Forward
Thinking in that respect one thing that
doesn't quite match with our example and
I don't think it's because it's bent I'd
have to check one of our others sorry
Museum Flex we do have more than one is
the angle of the case ejector can't be
sure that's not bent but as you can see
houses is counted quite far forward the
one on the game is pretty perpendicular
to the action I I haven't checked that
may not even be even the Minor error
that I'm
the game might be
oh set yourself on fire there
unfortunately good take I think on on
the flame throws uh we we are very lucky
in playing throws at the right armories
I've not fired a flamethrower I don't
know what it looks like from the point
of view of the shooter but this is
distinct distinctly different I think
the way it I think they've tried to
capture the fuel emitting from the
nozzle and being ignited a little bit
further out there's a there's a jet
effect there that I haven't seen done
before there seems to be some lofting of
the jet of fuel because fuel has weight
it's not just you know burning air or
something so that seems to be correctly
models uh the flame and smoke looks good
important thing is that the Flaming for
your sticks and burns uh even to
yourself if you're not careful which is
realistic if you set fire to a tree and
walk right past that tree it may well
may well certainly burn you whether it
would catch you on fire instantly like
that I don't know that's more of a
physics thing
foreign
German equivalent to the Garand roughly
I'm quite struck by the reflections off
the off the top of the receiver there
it's all looking really good in case if
anyone's wondering about the right hand
reload there that's completely period
correct in fact even the AK is was
designed for operation with the right
hand a lot of shooting military shooting
was taught from a prone position and
it's actually easier to operate a rifle
depending on its proportions in the
probe using your right hand so but and I
don't know the Vermax drills for this so
don't crucify me in the comments but
plausible enough that you would change
the magazine with the right hand we're
very fixated now with Opera with always
maintaining control with the right or
dominant hand on your pistol grip or the
rest of the right from this case but
that was not always the case
foreign
grease gun now this is that's even the
same same face model as the one from
Insurgency Sandstorm that we covered
recently I was impressed by that and I'm
impressed by this they're both really
good this is a conventional model not
suppressed without extra stuff stuck to
it I naturally lean toward this right
the size aperture on both guns is far
too wide we're moving on far too wide
but too wide but that's a that's a field
of view thing to enable the player to
see what the hell is going on overcoming
the limitations of a limited field of
view lack of depth perception and 2D
it's a concession to gain weight again
we have the big flappy dust cover that's
also a safety you can even see the felt
pad that's inside that it's a nice nice
touch the it all works as it ought to
including the Vault being closed after
you're done because there's no cartridge
power to power it back to the starting
position so you don't have to pull it
back to the starting position with the
slightly quaint lever cocking handle on
this on the side of this thing we again
have the Flappy dust cover on firing I
haven't done you know it anywhere near
enough grease gun shooting to say this
for sure but I as I've mentioned before
I don't think that would flap around as
much I haven't gone back and watched
Youtube footage or anything to sort of
determine that but maybe a worn gun it
would flap around
onto the the Lugo the the poh some are
of this era are not
p.08 for Parabellum model 1908 this one
is not nor is it the same as the one in
the game I've chosen this for something
a bit different this is um from the
Lesser known and less prolific Luger
manufacturer Creek hop and soul
beautifully finished they have they're
very they're sort of black on black a
gloss black very very highly polished on
the barrel on the slide or so I should
say the barrel extension or the toggle
and on parts of the frame but then other
parts of the frame are left matte so
it's quite a nice thing to look at in
terms of of How It's depicted uh no
complaints
um it's good play character is holding
the thing one hand which
correct for the period I don't think
you'll find anybody to handling a Luger
at this time if I have any observation
it would be that the sort of tactical
magazine eject is not realistic really
with the Luger the catch is very very
far forward and hard to reach you really
have to rotate it in your hands to reach
it and then yes the magazine will tend
to drop free that's true but at the time
I really don't think they were teaching
tactical reloads you would press the
catch whilst holding the base plate
remove the magazine something to bear in
mind about historic video games or
movies or anything like that is modern
practice modern position hold shooting
techniques are modern and although they
have their roots in the second world war
in many many cases to do it period
authentic you need to a look at training
manuals and B watch footage because
people obviously depart from their their
training in a war zone if you can speak
to the guys that were around then sadly
very few of them now uh even better
right the Winchester 1897 or m97 hasn't
abbreviated here the the infamous trench
gun with its heat shield and bayonet lug
it's known for its first world war usage
in fact if you head over to our website
our collection sites you'll find a
tucked away in the top right corner a
few sort of online exhibitions and one
of those is on the first world war we've
got some information and stats on there
some pictures of our example and some
footage and if you watch through to the
end we actually one of my colleagues
actually slam fires that gun into the
into the ground for safety because it's
hard to control a gun when you are
holding a trigger down and slamming the
pump brick forward which is how that
works and um we did not get the
impression that it was hugely effective
but obviously if you have the rounds and
time to practice you could become more
effective certainly the the version in
the game I haven't seen any ability to
slam fire and the rate of fire seems to
be fixed at red slow you can run a pump
gun faster than than we are here chances
are that's for gameplay reasons because
the 12 gauge round at close range was
then and is now extremely potent
all right mg42 a bit of hip firing here
now actually that's more plausible than
firing it from from the shoulder this
this is a beast it's extremely heavy
even without a belt box of however many
rounds you want to put on the side of it
it's going to avoid it's going to weigh
a ton you need you need some some upper
body strength to to wield this thing
which is of course the drawback of
compromising on a general purpose
machine gun that can do all the jobs
pretty much of a battlefield machine gun
is that in the light roll it's extremely
heavy obviously the high rate of fire
needs a bit of Trigger Discipline and
Trigger control so as to not slow the
gun off the target very quickly with the
mg42 you would need the belt box to make
it manageable as well otherwise you've
got a big flappy belt hanging outside of
your your gun and the technique we see
there of grasping a bipod that's a
genuine technique I don't know if it's
official but it's certainly what what
was done and the logic there is that you
don't want your hand anywhere near that
very hot Barrel because despite the fact
that it's in a inside a sheet metal heat
shield effectively it's still going to
be very hot very quickly so you hold the
bipod legs together and off to the side
like that to give you something to hang
on to basically
okay good depiction of the m1895 Nagant
Revolver I have one here this is a 1944
production example the uh
um Arsenal mark on the side there this
is a really nice depiction actually uh
the the way and this is generic to to
how the game depicts Firearms but very
sort of naturalistic feel to the way
it's being held the way it's with
coiling sort of wobbling about a bit
which is which is quite realistic if
you're you're pulling through
on the double action trigger it disturbs
your aim and you're going to get that
slightly bouncy wobbly shooting that we
saw in the in the footage the rear sight
on the Gantt is Tiny don't get me wrong
it's not quite as Tiny as it's depicted
here uh the hammer when it's down for
double action mode does obscure the
bottom part of the site so something I
never noticed before actually with this
is that you do have to [__] the hammer
to get the full sight picture which is
actually quite a major design floor in
my view but um only in principle because
if you're having to pull through on the
trigger for the double action Paul
you're not going to be super accurate
anyway and I'm sure that's what they
were thinking when they when they
designed it so that that's all this is
all correct but the hammer should not
obscure as much of the rear sight Notch
as it does here that's borderline
unusable I would suggest uh for combat
purposes you should be able to see about
twice as much of the front side when
it's aligned
foreign
Springfield 1903 a standard service
rifle of first world war although not as
common as the Enfield uh still in use is
a standard service rifle in second world
war for the US Marine Corps so this was
this was a Springfield model 1903 A3
which was the
standard of the era there are
differences in the form of the controls
there are differences here that's to do
with the model the specific variant of
the model of sight which is a weaver
model 330. these are both Weaver 330.
Optics but yeah a few differences which
are not
errors in the game and there's
differences between our rifle and box
scope and the one that's depicted the
reticle in this is a tapered post which
was not uncommon at that time and the
crosshairs I'm not familiar enough with
Weaver sights to to be 100 sure but I
would imagine that that's an updated
form with a more modern Crosshair style
of reticle
and the spt-40 not very much to say
about this like a lot of the guns in
this game it's
good maybe and I haven't got one handy
to double check but the magazine
insertion might be a little bit too
straight in if that makes sense but I
can't even be sure of that without
checking so I'm I'm really reaching
because this thing looks great sounds
good
thanks very much for watching everybody
we actually here at the Royal armories
have quite an interesting event coming
up that I'm starting to to mention which
is on the 11th of March it's actually a
whole weekend here at the Royal armories
in Leeds that is themed around historic
Firearms which is nice watch us do a
version of our own YouTube series
um what is this weapon and there's also
going to be a meet and greet with me and
probably some other stuff going on that
day as well so do check that out if
you're able to join us if not we'll see
you again obviously on our on over on
our Channel and here on Gamespot as well
every week thanks very much
[Music]
foreign